all right in 2016 remember then
candidate Trump he promised to reshape
the US Supreme Court he wanted to put on
people that were originally
constitutionalist those people as judges
not people that legislate from the bench
well tonight President Trump has words
only fulfilled yet another campaign
promise
judge Brett Kavanaugh is now officially
been sworn in as the newest member of
the US Supreme Court a lifetime
appointment making him now the second
judge successfully sent to this bench by
the president and tonight during his
where if wearing in ceremony the
president he congratulated judge
Cavanaugh he also apologized for the
horrific nomination process that we all
witnessed for almost three straight
weeks take a look on behalf of our
nation I want to apologize to Brett and
the entire Cavanaugh family for the
terrible pain and suffering you have
been forced to endure those who step
forward to serve our country deserve a
fair and dignified evaluation not a
campaign of political and personal
destruction based on lies and deception
what happened to the Cavanaugh family
violates every notion of fairness
decency and due process our country a
man or a woman must always be presumed
innocent unless and until proven guilty
presumption of innocence it is core to
who we are George Brett Kavanaugh had
this to say about his historic
nomination let's take a look at that
article 3 of the Constitution provides
that the judicial power shall be vested
in one Supreme Court the Supreme Court
is an institution of law it is not a
partisan or political institution the
justices do not sit on opposite sides of
an aisle we do not caucus in separate
rooms the Supreme Court is a team of
nine and I will always be a team player
on the team of nine
I was not appointed to serve one party
or one interest but to serve one nation
America's Constitution and laws protect
every person of every belief and every
backgrounds every litigant in the
Supreme Court can be assured that I'll
listen to their arguments with respect
and in open minds now in the face of one
of the most despicable disgusting
political hit jobs ever in our history
well judge Brett Kavanaugh just made
history now from the very beginning the
day that Justice Kennedy announced his
retirement right here on this program
I warned you all of this would happen
now tonight we begin thanks to all of
you this is now the beginning of my 23rd
consecutive year right here on the Fox
News Channel and over the course of that
period we have chronicled all of this
for you
it is the Democratic playbook we get
this all the time Robert Bork Clarence
Thomas and now they did it to justice
Cavanaugh and his two young girls and
his wife and his family what this is
about is about power the left will stop
at nothing when it comes to blocking a
nomination a winning an election elected
Democrats openly even accusing Cavanaugh
of gang rape and drugging teenage girls
on a regular almost weekend basis
calling him evil comparing him to Bill
Cosby and so much more and with
zero-zero corroborating evidence zero
corroborating witnesses and it was based
on what nearly four decades old claims
and most of them had holes and
inconsistencies all over the place now
this kind of guilt by accusation was
parented by the so-called news media in
this country including the late-night
so-called common comedian and comedy
shows with the far-left holier-than-thou
host like Stephen Colbert over the
weekend we had a writer for Colbert's
Late Night show actually tweeting this
whatever happens I'm just glad we ruined
Bret Cavanaugh's life just for a second
stand back think how ugly and despicable
disgusting that is well she later
apologized and she
sarcastic nothing funny that tweet sums
up pretty much what we have witnessed
now for far too many elections far too
many confirmations in this country and
unfortunately it's all they're offering
you the American people in 29 days the
politics of personal destruction their
motivations they it's clear it's obvious
it's transparent they want to regain
power and they do it try to make
conservatives as evil as you possibly
can and as you can imagine well they're
taking the cavanaugh then I've taken the
Kavanagh confirmation tonight very well
gee this is a shocker take a look this
is the institutionalization of tribalism
on the court
women who are shrieking out in agony
saying you cannot impose this on us you
can't send us back to the 50s but Mitch
McConnell says yes I can this is a
president who says he's for law and
order but not when it comes to sexual
assault that's quite clear I think this
is in many ways a crushing defeat for
women and women's rights
Trump has delivered for these people on
the things that they care about most he
has delivered racism for these people he
has delivered misogyny for these people
and now he's delivered the Supreme Court
for these people we're gonna see if this
if this reign that they now have control
over all three branches of government
we're gonna see if this rain lasts for
30 days or two years 1,000 year bike
now after senator Susan Collins issued a
historic address and bravely cast what
was the deciding vote sending judge
Kavanagh to the bench
Oh recently senator Collins her staff
get this receiving rape threats death
threats other derogatory calls an op-ed
in the New York Times entitled white
women come get your people
slamming Collins and any woman that
thought different than they did and
supported Kavanagh calling them quote
gender traitors over at NBC News an
op-ed led with the headline quote Brett
Cavanaugh's confirmation is the ultimate
affirmation of the patriarchy and
Republican women let it happen next
there is known anti-semite anti Sharia
law or Sharia law advocate
Linda Sarsour really she's helping
organize the women's March P and
actually introduced senator Kirsten
Gillibrand in New York at an anti
Cavanaugh protest a woman that tweeted
out quote that Senator Collins is called
a disgrace and her legacy legacy will be
that she was a traitor to women and
marginalized communities history will
not treat her kindly cancel Cavanaugh
hashtag as you can see devoid of any new
ideas to help improve our country make
us more secure more prosperous look at
what Democrats do they divide Americans
this is what identity politics is every
two years every four years you watch
elections what a liberals do what does
the Democratic Party do they call
Republicans and conservatives racist
sexist misogynistic xenophobic
homophobic Islamophobic they want dirty
air in water Republicans want to take
your grandma on a wheelchair and throw
them over a cliff and they want to kill
children it's nothing new this is their
playbook don't take my word for it
we have been chronicling a history of
slander character assassination
character bludgeoning by the left for
now as we begin our 23rd year four
decades on this program take a look
many Republicans talking coated racial
language about takers and losers they
demonize President Obama and encourage
the ugliest impulses of the paranoid
fringe if you accept the support of Klan
sympathizers before you are president
you will accept their support after
you're president he's gonna let the big
banks once again write their own rules
Unchained Wall Street
they're gonna put y'all back in Chains
it's wrong what the leader of the
Republican Party and this Congress are
doing in blocking an accurate census
because they don't want to count
everyone that they don't think they can
count on they are in favor of
affirmative action if you can dunk the
basketball or sink a 3-point shot but
they're not in favor of it if you merely
have the potential to be a leader in
your community and bring people together
don't tell me you let another Church
explode when you don't vote
you allow another cross to burn
and then you got their plan which is
let's have dirty or air dirtier water
less people with health insurance see we
don't just make this stuff up this is
what they say every two and four years
tonight while the states could not be
any higher because in 29 days if we the
American people reward this party for
these despicable disgusting tactics we
all know what's gonna happen now I have
warned you over and over again they
don't have a plan the Democratic Party
to make your life better
about the Forgotten men and women of
this country clearly they are destroyed
Trump every minute every second every
hour of every day they want impeachment
open borders get rid of ice they want to
keep Obamacare how's that working and
remember the tax cuts that have now
created four million jobs got four
million Americans off of food stamps
they want their crumbs back but again
don't take Hannity's word for it listen
for yourself they are telling you what
they want to do in 29 days if we are
stupid enough to give them back power
take a look they say Maxine please don't
say impeachment anymore in terms of the
bonus that corporate America received
versus the crumbs that they are giving
to workers to kind of but the schmooze
Owen is so pathetic they should once and
for all work with us to improve the
Affordable Care Act and renounce repeal
once and for all as well we've got to
critically re-examine ice and its role
and the way that it is being
administered and the work it is doing
and we need to probably think about
starting from scratch we should protect
families that need our help and that is
not what ice is doing today and that's
why I believe you should get rid of it
start over
reimagine it 29 days to go until the
most important midterms in our country's
history the fate of the country is
resting in your hands we ultimately have
the power so let's set the stage
first it's so important to remember
the party that controls the presidency
has gained seats in the House of
Representatives only three times in the
last hundred years last time was in 2002
after 9/11 the stakes have never been
this high so will you the American
people reward these despicable
disgusting political tactics from a
party that has no plan to make your life
better or will you ask yourself you know
this simple question are you is America
better off than we were two years ago is
the country better off is America
stronger is America safer is the economy
doing better is the president keeping
promises that he made to you the
American people look at your screen now
the answer to those questions you'll
never see this on any other show well
look at the answers right there
overwhelming success the unemployment
rate in this country dropped to its
lowest level in nearly 50 years 1969 the
Mets won the World Series it's now at
3.7 percent Hispanic unemployment in
America all-time low we're seeing
historic unemployment lows for African
Americans Asian Americans Hispanic
Americans women in the workforce youth
unemployment we have record low
unemployment now in 14 states out of our
50 States manufacturing confidence at an
all-time high
by the way 400,000 new manufacturing
jobs brought back to america jobs Obama
said we're never coming back
consumer confidence all-time high four
million fewer people tonight on food
stamps than two years ago eight million
people out of poverty that's happened in
two years three plus trillion dollars
spent on securing our borders and
building the wall that's underway the
president kept his promise on NAFTA he
pulled us out of the catastrophic
Iranian deal and don't forget about the
historic progress that's going on now we
haven't seen a missile from little
rocket man since December last year is
like a missile a day being fired by
little rocket man president now making
progress we might be able to have
denuclearization of the entire peninsula
in the Korean
Peninsula we have new pipelines that
have been opened up that's American jobs
that's American energy sector now
booming in this country
Anwar is now open coal miners jobs have
been saved in West Virginia to
originalist on the US Supreme Court
confirmed
we now have promises made promises kept
two years President Trump has kept his
promise and again his agenda is
reshaping the country for the better but
tonight that agenda 29 days from now is
in jeopardy our booming economy in
jeopardy look closely if you live in one
of those house districts that you see in
yellow on your screen look closely
because those districts are the ones
that will decide whether or not Nancy
Pelosi will become the next Speaker of
the House because Pelosi well she's
already measuring the drapes and
planning on what endless investigation
after investigation even into the newly
appointed Supreme Court justice justice
Cavanaugh sore-loser on top of all the
other investigations the house is
planning to go after President Trump two
years non-stop they're on a quest
they've been telegraphing it they want
to impeach this president and all they
want is a majority from you to fulfill
their seedy dreams and meanwhile if you
live in one of these states you're gonna
decide the future of the United States
Senate by the way look how close the
vote was this weekend you live in North
Dakota senator Heidi Heitkamp well she
gave into the Democratic mob she voted
against judge Cavanaugh and so too did
Joe Donnelly in Indiana and so too did
Bill Nelson in Florida and so too did
all of these Democrats with the
exception of one Joe Manchin of West
Virginia there are no more moderates
left in the Democratic Party there's no
diversity of opinion anymore
the Democratic Party is evolved into a
party of the radical far left and then
not thinking about how to help the
American people with jobs and security
it's a party that has proven in the last
three weeks that they have a disdain
even for our US Constitution which
should be nonpartisan which we all love
and basic principles which should unite
a
not divide us due process the
presumption of innocence they've now
become the party of smears lies slander
piss murchman and bludgeoning the party
of identity politics now in 29 days
every American in every corner of this
great country you've got to rise up and
send a message
Democrats their brand of ruthless
ruthless politics
you cannot reward people for what they
do every two in four years what they've
done the last three weeks if you don't
get to the polls and vote core
principles that we all hold dearly are
at stake this is the most important
midterm election in our lifetime